guten tag der verehrte zuschauer ich
stehen carina schmidt küche und ich weiß
nicht warum wird mich eingeladen
richtig wir stellen ja normalerweise
fragen auf der straße rollen
und heute habe aber eine frage die wir
nicht an deutsche stellen wollten
denn wir wollten die antworten von allen
anderen menschen nur nicht von deutschen
und zwar das thema ist heute was ist
typisch deutsch aber aus der sicht von
nichtdeutschen und deswegen habe ich
meine kleine umfrage gemacht ich mag das
ja manchmal sogar facebook einfach meine
frage zu stellen und zu gucken was
passiert also ich habe auf meiner
facebook privaten facebook warnt gefragt
was ist typisch deutsch geschrieben und
das gleiche habe ich dann zwei wochen
später noch mal bei ihnen wiederholt und
haben über 300 leute geantwortet aus
irgendwie 50 ländern reichweite hast du
es war auf jeden fall großartig weil er
kein super super gute antworten und die
wollte ich jetzt mal mit ihm sprechen
und du bist sozusagen unser testkandidat
du kennst die antworten nicht du musst
immer sagen ja stimmt nein stimmt nicht
richtig oder falsch dass genau das
hätten wir auch ein diadem ist an wir
werden am rausziehen bist du zu besteht
oder nicht
okay ich bin bereit liefern an mit dem
ersten thema das sind schon mal grob
gefasst gegenstände und essen sachen die
angeblich die besteuert sind ich war
kurz mit einem beispiel noch an bevor du
loslegst
hier ist ein gegenstand fleisch essen
fache was typisch deutsch ist angela
merkel vom zitronenpresse genau richtig
warum nicht nur als beispiel wie das
ganze funktioniert met you here wand
schreibt aus zuletzt wurde stupid
shericka williams jam in der stuhl ist
typisch leute ich hasse sie gerne aber
langsam auch aus ist ein bisschen
überbleibsel aus der vergangenheit in
ein bisschen schneller pfandflaschen
kopfsteinpflaster scheiße für
rennradfahrer sie mit rabatt schule
apfelsaft schon oft ja ich trinke ich
jeden tag auf das bin dass nicht nur
deutschland bin ich also ich kann
wirklich drei stunden frühstücken und
das machen auch andere deutsche aber
definitiv mein hobby
ich hasse das warme getränke im sommer
schreibt eine amerikanerin nämlich kelz
wie von mir university of california in
santa barbara
der amerikaner hatte schon mehrfach
wieder beschweren sich dass die
deutschen immer warme getränke haben in
amerika zeit alles gekühlt rettenden mit
des rades mit fleisch habe ich nicht mit
am hut hausschuhe ja obwohl ich warme
socken bevorzuge aber viele leute daran
rasch vergessen autobahn kaffee und
kuchen kartoffeln reis kartoffeln sind
lecker was ist deine lieblings kartoffel
zubereitungsmethode bratkartoffeln liebe
auch so richtig cross getrennte
bratkartoffeln hefeweizen ja einen süden
von deutschland wir überall und wir dann
kommt bratwurst salat und gern was alles
leider deutsche phänomene nicht ich bin
nicht so der fleisch gut und wir haben
da muss man wirklich sagen das beste
brot auf der welt nirgendwo gibt so viel
gutes in deutschland bekannteste
gegenstand haben ganz schön socken in
sandalen
das ist furchtbar aber das gehört leider
auch noch ständig dafür zufallsauswahl
jahresstart fekter wir geben zum
nächsten und zwar jetzt geht es darum
wie sind die deutschen eher sind jetzt
eigenschaften und du musst nur ja oder
nein sagen bist du so oder nicht okay es
geht um mit seinen german faktor ist
besserwisser problemorientiert nicht
spontan open minded sicher das geschirr
das ist ja nicht die lieben recycling
humorvoll
erlebt haben nur zwei leute von 300
geschäft
sie lieben wenn jemand in ausländer
versucht deutsch zu sprechen ist cool
sind freundlich manchmal sehen jetzt
welche antworten die selten kamen aber
jetzt etwas kommt häufig effizienz
definitiv wirklich praktisch veranlagt
ja logisch denken ich mich so called vom
auszeit bat warminski cables bisschen
hard working und fleißig und jetzt
kommen wir zu den topf antworten
erhältst zweiten akkurat und genau alles
mit ganz genauen bestimmung abgerechnet
ja ich bin sehr akkurat stimmt direkt
und ehrlich bin ich auch und 50 top
antwort bin ich definitiv auch ja aber
bei mir und mich heißt dann eher so drei
minuten zu spielen zunächst und 25 kann
zumal passieren aber das geht ja in
anderen ländern auch härter und jetzt
kommen wir zum zum dritten thema heute
manuellen dinge die wir machen und du
musst mir gedanken machst du das auch
oder was es nicht braucht wird auch was
mich okay wir fangen an mit sie brauchen
social space also quasi ein bisschen
abstand italiener reden
na ja man braucht seine konflikte nicht
beschweren
ich mache das nicht so oft aber es ist
schon etwas sehr deutsches ich total
habe ich ja jetzt gerade im video in
ägypten gesagt und auch an mir selber
festgestellt deutschen beginnen ihren
satz immer mit nein und vier leute
geschickt aufgefallen aber ich achte mal
drauf kann schon sein deutsch ist stark
ja das stimmt also das fällt mir
manchmal auch an mir selbst auch dass
ich wenn ich in der u bahn sitzen
fachleute an starre und ich meine das
gar nicht böse ist einfach interessant
sich leute anzuschauen aber in anderen
kulturen gibt es gar nicht in amerika
ist das ganz ganz um hilfe
blumen mitbringen wie man jemanden
besucht lüften und hey lüften ist
wichtig dazu kommt nesrin schreibt no
matter how colt ist ein hoch frische
luft wohl kaum next un opening window
das ist richtig dass man mindestens
zweimal am tag die wohnung gut
durchlüftete steht bei mir im
mietvertrag weil sonst schimmel sich
bildet weil unsere wohnungen sind so gut
isoliert dass man ihm nicht viel energie
braucht zum heizen nur wenn du nicht
zweimal am tag luft ist und zwar gut
läuft ist mit frischer luft dann kriegt
ihr im schnitt sehr akkurat deutsche
mögen es nicht zu verhandeln
ja haben wir ein bisschen angst vor das
stimmt mögen keinen smalltalk stimmt
auch dass das gut germany dance und
schlager wird bei aus mac fan of people
who like to listen to schlager ja und
wir können auch nicht tanzen ist das
problem
das kommt auch noch nennen sie körper
zweite long time since i lived in
germany batman year sylvie testud people
continually etwa windows know what s
going on in the neighborhood ja es gibt
also ein typisches phänomen so alte frau
oder alter mann schön mit kissen auf dem
fenstersims und dann soll ich sind aus
der straße raus schauen was da passiert
sei die geilste überhaupt letzte woche
war ich in gremmendorf bei münster und
christ das zu suchen ich habe geparkt
auf der anderen straßenseite von einer
einfahrt also nicht vor der einfahrt und
das stand schon ein trieb am fenster der
kann direkt raus und als ich ausstieg
sagte er mit halo oder guten tag junge
frau sondern da wo wir nicht stehen
bleiben
ich bin stehen bleiben den weg ja was
dir in den weg wenn ich ein bisschen
zurück fahre ist es dann okay da sehen
sie erholen und hat die tür zu
willkommen in burg im dorf im dorf im
dorf
ja ich fand es furchtbar aber das
passiert in deutschland kommt aber noch
horst alles schreit die besteht ist
samstags um 8 uhr aufstehen und die
straße wegen hauptsache wir zumindest da
wo ich wohne hauptsache was geschafft
haben am samstag noch gehört zu manchen
orten auch zur pflicht als bürger auch
im schnee weg schicken
würde ich nie machen ahlmann sogar
gemacht irgendwann al mana jahre
schreibt können nicht gut dass heute
kein überhaupt ich bin furchtbar haben
wir einfach nicht im blut ist ok man
kann mich anrufen kann ja nicht alles
konnten die ticketkäufer abschreiben
fußgängerzonen inside the city where you
can't fröhlich shootout cars and without
having to own story stammt ist das
deutsche ist glaube ich schon im
amerikanischen nation was wie der name
schon sagt es für fußgänger als mich für
autos palin crash ja das interessante
sind die deutschen wirklich
spitzenreiter wir haben da so ein
bisschen zweifel dass mit den
kreditkarten und so das ist alles so
funktionieren kann
17 noch ein bisschen der schock
vielleicht von der depression im nacken
von der wagen von 1929
nein wirklich ich glaube dass viele
leute das einfach noch ein ungutes
gefühl ist geld irgendwie auf seiner
karte kann das funktionieren lieber
bargeld das hat man in der hand seit
ja und passend dazu having the search
for bank money out es der in cash
machine and cash is king getrennt
one to pay karte fehlt allerdings auch
böse blicke wenn du im supermarkt mit
einem 50 euro schein bezahlen wird
manchmal bei uns muss man passend sein
er recht
ich hoffe dass auch ich war letztens
wieder mit den automaten suchen oder
müsst ihr erstmal fahren ähnlich wie in
berlin oder einfach zur nächsten ecke
furchtbar gut mal das waren unsere
typisch solchen sachen zu guter letzt
habe ich jetzt noch mal unsere top 5
ausgeschrieben die top fünf antworten
wie kam das ist ein mix herz nahm und
zwar nummer fünf ist payback und burca
sie haben ganz viele leute geschrieben
ja das ist wirklich furchtbar also
allein was es braucht um sich in einer
stadt an oder abzumelden
ist doch sehr aufwändig in deutschland
in anderen ländern ist es deutlich
einfacher kann ich aus eigener erfahrung
bestätigen ich habe mich gerade in der
schweiz abgemeldet und es hat ungefähr
zwei minuten gedauert und ich brauchte
kein papier garten
ich habe den meine neue adresse gesagt
ihr seid alles clutches das war top 5
aber ich habe keinen druck springt
direkt zu top 3 deutsche müssen alles
planen und das schreibt martin rosowski
organisieren social spontanes live
bestimmt also ich trag mir sogar im
kalender ein wenig geschick und ich weiß
auch morgen um 9 uhr die glocken nicht
spontan sein ich bin für mich ist es
einfach ein gutes gefühl zu wissen was
kommt als nichts ich bin doch auf sich
gestellt und man sich dafür ein kaffee
verabredet und dann wird man erst mal so
er war mit nachlässen von kaffee und
dann jemand anderes würde sagen schön
sprechen und die tage und der deutsche
schlägt bevor beim terminkalender
augenblick um die nächsten drei
wochenenden geht gar nicht im fleisch in
vier wochen am sonntag um 16 uhr
gründungstreffen schönefeld aber auch
positive seiten wenn man plant dann
passieren die dinge auch wenn man
einfach sagt ja machen wir sondern
passiert vielleicht mich sehr gut
so sind die deutschen immer effizient
sogar die sozialen kontakte müssen
effizient durchzuführen seien
top 2 doch zweimal ordnungs treue
alles verläuft ordnungsgemäß wir
deutschen lieben regeln beispiel
schreibt sarah aus köln hatte 3 sie
schreibt waiting adtraffic ipad 3 m in
the morning hat das für 26 likes
bekommen gesetzt so ein bisschen
abhängig davon wo man es in münchen kann
ich das bestätigen da machen dass die
leute wirklich tut mir leid mit china
aber es ist wirklich sorgt in berlin
stimmt nicht da gab es noch eine
diskussion darunter andreas lipp
darunter we don't even been bord unserer
reise schreibt end ist der knock outs
und beißt an dass bei stan das schaut
sind sie blind es ist doch rot und das
ist typisch deutsch man misst ist nicht
nur selber nicht auch die anderen
zuordnung zu einer ordnungswidrigkeit
die ich gefährlich finde
jannis kritisiert dass auch gesagt es
ist hier wie im kommunismus
ja und es kann man leicht ausnutzen weil
wenn man einfach andere regeln aufstellt
die vielleicht moralisch falsch sind und
trotzdem alle die dann befolgen und
darüber nachzudenken es gefährlich
regelrecht die regeln so viel ihr könnt
wichtig sei jetzt ob ein
ich bin gespannt michael kölbl anders
sind schreibt aus dänemark germans are
from others to help die feinen dämpfers
38 tage durchschnitt gerade macht
süchtig ja liebe leute das war's schon
mit unserem video heute hier zonen dass
ich eure kommentare müssen wir freuen
uns drauf
wir werden alles durchlesen manuela
genau das was was für eine frage stellen
wie man muss an habe ich gelernt bei
youtube bei meinem am ende muss man
immer nur frage stellen jetzt schon im
raum was ist typisch deutsch noch weiter
genau wo es noch gucken was ihr dazu
sagt haben wir etwas vergessen haben wir
etwas komisch beantwortet ist manuel
dieser typisch deutsch für euch oder
nicht das ist natürlich ist das eine
gute frage was möchte ich auch wissen
ich dachte erst ich bin gar nicht
besteuert bis ins ausland gefahren wenn
da richte mich gott oh gott ich bin
deutsch und nach einer weile gewöhnt man
sich dran und dann irgendwann ist man
auch sonst braucht das man nicht spontan
ist auch nicht halten kann und alles
oder sein zumindest legal und wackelt
nicht auch noch mal sagen müssen
natürlich ist uns bewusst also mir ist
zumindest bewusst dass das eine
kategorisierung ist jeder ist natürlich
ein bisschen anders aber trotzdem gibt
es ja bestimmte kulturelle unterschiede
und die sind ja interessant zu erörtern
ja das glaube ich auch wenn ihr lust
habt noch übungen zu bekommen könnt ihr
einpendeln werden zum beispiel hier oder
hier oder hier und was auch noch richtig
ist kari auf die glocke müsst ihr
drücken dann kriegt ihr immer eine
nachricht werden einzige von islamisten
handelt dass du hast ja danke für die
einladung
ich denke freudig bald ich freue mich zu
sehen wie wir uns bald mal wieder
definitiv gelb